llegó la ayuda a shanghai desde
distintas provincias más de 10.000
trabajadores de la salud y 2.000 médicos
militares viajaron este lunes a la
ciudad más grande de china para ayudar a
realizar pruebas y ofrecer tratamientos
médicos contra el cubit 19 una
estrategia adicional desplegada en la
ciudad que se encuentra bajo un estricto
confinamiento sectorizado debido al
aumento de contagios atribuidos a la
variante omicron con más de 25 millones
de habitantes a la mayoría de los
ciudadanos de shanghai solo se les
permite salir de sus casas para
abastecerse de alimentos o para hacerse
pruebas masivas para lograr una
distribución sin contacto ponemos el
autodiagnóstico en la puerta de nuestros
vecinos y llamamos a la puerta hola su
kit de prueba de antígeno se ha colocado
en la puerta después de la prueba por
favor coloque el lado con los resultados
y lo recogeremos
más hacia el sur en el territorio
semiautónomo de hong kong el brote de
kobe 19 ha cobrado la vida de más de
8000 personas desde el inicio de la
pandemia en donde más del 95% de los
fallecimientos se han registrado entre
febrero y marzo de este año una crítica
cifra de muertes que incluso ha
sobrepasado la capacidad de ataúdes de
los proveedores de la ciudad ahora las
empresas entregan féretros de cartón y
algunas ong han donado cientos de ellos
para la distribución en hospitales
públicos
en la sala de urgencias hay muchos
cuerpos que hay que guardar en bolsas
esto provoca dos problemas el primero es
que los profesionales médicos se están
quedando sin espacio y el segundo es que
para las familias de los pacientes o
para la gente en el hospital no es algo
muy agradable de ver dónde está
con su estricta política de 'cero cobit
el gobierno chino ha demostrado que
haría lo necesario para evitar la
propagación del virus mientras también
se niega a tener cierres totales en sus
ciudades evitando que se entorpezca la
economía nacional y las negociaciones
internacionales
[Música]